hello everyone i am pleased to
announce that my course on the essentials
of ere for ecologists is now
fully recorded in spanish and that
we will launch it soon this is thanks to the
amazing wakin carroro an
ecologist biologist and r&d guru from argentina who has
done a great job  incredible by re-recording
my course in Spanish with that I am going to
let the present of the course
hello to all to all my name is with a
car I am a biologist ecologist and
I always wanted to do a course in which I
would have wanted to have me when
I started with my  doctorate
in the most difficult parts of doing
data analysis in ecology has to
do with getting a whiff of the
r tool and it's a shame because it's
a tool that should make
the process easier for us to do
better quality science instead of hampering and
that everything is so difficult that we
can never finish our analysis the
main point of this course is to try
to eliminate that frustration and that
initial need  that we have when we
hit the new programming environment
so that we can start cleaning
and working with our data to
visualize and analyze it with some
comfort and with some confidence the
project-based lessons that
we have in this course are designed
to go hand in hand  through
the most essential things of
the r programming environment from how to install it
how the rest will be
going through how to start cleaning and
ordering our data to the
basic visualization tools such as
line graphs, box
graphs or graphs  dispersion now this course
doesn't cover any kind of
statistical analysis the same kind of modeling
that the perez guy is really the point
there are a lot of ecology courses
out there that try to cover everything and that
can be very frustrating especially for
beginners or for  For people who
have never worked in a programming environment,
this course is geared towards  It is intended
for postgraduate
ecology students but it is really applicable to
anyone who wants to start
having some knowledge about the
basic fundamentals of programming
of nothing
if you are interested in this
course look at the link in the
description of this
video registration for this
initial release will only be open for one
week so do it as soon
as you can
thank you very much for the videos and
please share it with anyone
you think might be interested in
doing this course
[Music]